let's see if we can multiply nine times
zero point six nine times zero point six
or another way to write it we want to
calculate nine times zero point six I'll
write it like this
zero point six we want to figure out
what this is equal to and I encourage
you to pause the video and try to figure
it out on your own and I'll give you a
little bit of a hint 0.6 0.6 is the same
thing as 6 divided by 6 divided by 10 we
know that if we start with 6 which we
could write as 6.0 and if you were to
divide it by 10 dividing by 10 is
equivalent to moving the decimal place
one place to the left so 6 divided by 10
is 0.6 we're moving the decimal one
place to the left so I'm assuming you've
given a go at it but what I'm going to
do is use this that we already know to
rewrite what we're trying to multiply so
9 times 0.6 is the same thing as 9 times
0.6 is 6 divided by divided by 10 and
this expression right over here we could
either do the 6/10 first in which case
we would get to 0.6 and this would it
would turn into this problem or we could
do the 9 times 6 first and so let's do 9
times 6 which we know how to calculate
and then divide by 10 which we also know
how to do that's all about just moving
the decimal place so we could write 9 9
times 6 9 times 6 we already know is 54
that in orange is going to be 54 so this
right over here is 54 and now to get to
this expression we have to divide by 10
we have to divide by 10 and what happens
when we divide something by 10 and we've
seen this in previous videos why this is
the case this is all about what decimal
notation means each place is 10 to the
place it represents 10 times as much as
the place to that's right or each place
represents one
tenth of the place to the left so 54
divided by 10 this is going to be you
could start with 54 54 and I'll put a
zero here after the decimal and when you
divide by 10 that's equivalent of
shifting the decimal one to the left
this is going to be equal to five point
four and that should make sense to you
five times ten is fifty point four times
ten is four so it makes sense that 54
divided by 10 54 divided say equalize
I'd write 54 divided by 10 is equal to
five point four so this right over here
is equal to five point four and that's
what this is this is equal to five point
four notice 9 times 6 is 54 9 times zero
point six is five point four now you
might see a little pattern here between
these two numbers I had exactly one
number to the right of the decimal when
I take its products let's say I ignored
the decimal I just said nine times six I
would've gotten 54 but then I had to
divide by 10 in order to take account of
the decimal take account of the fact
that this wasn't a six this was a six
tense and so I have one number to the
right of the decimal here and I want you
to think about whether that's a general
principle can we just count the total
numbers of digits to the right of the
decimals and then our product is going
to have the same number of digits to the
right of the decimal I'll let you think
about that